[Music]
in a lot of families conversations about
sex go something like this
good talk or if words are exchanged
they're so uncomfortable and so vague
the very little gets communicated this
was not the case in my family and my
family conversations about sex were
normal common and open there is no more
emblematic example than the famous
orgasm talk from my dad when my brother
got his first girlfriend he got the how
to please a women talk for my dad my dad
got this talk from his father so when I
was 19 and my Catholic mother still have
it had not given me the orgasm talk my
dad decided he was going to recite the
latest research literature to me about
the female orgasm I was 19 and my
Stanford undergrad dorm room not far
from here talk went something like this
Jackie Hollywood makes it look like sex
is all about intercourse but only 15% of
women can have an orgasm from
intercourse alone the vast majority of
women need clitoral stimulation then he
said and it's really important that a
women be pleased first in bed why when a
man has an orgasm it's over so the woman
needs to be pleased first at the time I
thought my dad was just so quirky and
I'm still the first to admit that he is
very quirky but what I realize now is
that the result also so much power and
wisdom and what my dad was telling the
19 year-old me so often in our culture a
woman sexual well-being
is valued less than a man's we see that
not only in relationships oftentimes but
also in our broader business systems you
may have heard that this January at CES
the largest consumer electronics trade
show a woman's vibrator company got an
award but then how'd the award rescinded
and was not allowed to present at the
conference CES called the product
profane and immoral and yet dedicated an
entire room for VR porn for male users
and has prominently featured sex robots
and other sexual products geared at men
what I want to show today is that CES
was not a one-off issue our business
practices systematically discriminate
against female sexual wellness compared
to male sexual wellness I could give you
scores of examples but I'm going to talk
about advertising financial institutions
and manufacturing first advertising ride
the subway in New York City and you
cannot escape the massive amounts of
admira's
for erectile dysfunction also on the
radio TV and all across ads right now
hims youth shows penises to erect
cactuses to represent penises and Roman
offers to deliver IDI drugs directly to
your door one might wonder where are the
odds for women sexual wellness products
this advertisement was for a woman
sexual wellness company called unbound
in the same subways in New York City
banned these advertisements they
wouldn't post them why they were
considered too phallic again cactus is
to represent erect penises yet the
women's sexual wellness company this was
too phallic
yeah this is not just the New York
subway and it's not just Edie Facebook
Pinterest snapchat and Instagram have
many advertisements not only for
erectile disfunction but also for penis
enlargement pumps male sexual enhancer
gels playboy all kinds of products
addressing men's sexual needs but van
not only female sexual wellness and
pleasure companies but also sex
education companies and even products
that prevent pain for women during
intercourse second financial
institutions stripe has a policy against
working with all sex toys stripe itself
considers this policy to be outdated and
overly moralizing but the issue is that
its partners banks and credit card
companies will not do business with sex
toy companies they're considered too
much of a brand risk the thing is sex
toys are much more commonly used by
women than they are by men so practices
that say no to doing business with these
companies disproportionately impact
companies that address women sexual
needs as context 53% of American women
use a vibrator 40% have used one with a
partner and vibrator usage is associated
with better sexual function for women
across every measure arousal lubrication
desire lack of pain and orgasm but this
entire category of product is banned not
just from working with payment
processors like stripe but from opening
a bank account if the bank knows what
the company does and from getting loans
from the bank this applies not only to
sex toy companies but again to sex
education sites such as oMG s which
conducted the first large-scale study
about female pleasure and was working to
educate the mass public about it third
manufacturing an entrepreneur an
entrepreneur named Melanie crystal left
a partner track career in law to
a product that was initially intended to
address and prevent STI transmission for
oral sex on a woman it got a factory
that was really excited to work with it
was a condom manufacturer but as soon as
the factory realized the product was for
oral sex men and women it backed out of
working with the company and said it was
against their show like their
shareholder values basic steps for
businesses like getting a manufacturer
packaging partner or product liability
insurance are huge barriers still for
companies that address female sexual
wellness one result of all of these
norms both in business and in our
culture today although 95 percent of men
say they have an orgasm always or almost
always when they have sex that figure is
only 65 percent for heterosexual women
which a lot of us still feel still think
sounds high this is not because women
are just not orgasmic definitely not the
case in fact lesbian women have orgasms
essentially as much as men and research
shows that women who by themselves
achieve orgasm easily in within minutes
the difference in the gap is because of
a lack of understanding about female
pleasure but also a lack of value in our
culture of female pleasure compared to
male sexual pleasure we have historical
precedence both for female sexual health
products being embraced much more slowly
than men's products but also for
changing this when it came to Conte oral
contraceptives the birth control pill
which came out in 1960 for 40 years this
was the only prescription drug that
insurance wouldn't cover women's groups
long thought to change this women were
paying more in medical bills than men
because of this and they had little real
success what changed this 1998
viagra came out it was covered by half
of insurers in the United States
quickly prescriptions were quickly
prescribed and it was only after viagra
came out that women's groups could
effectively argue this was
discrimination and successfully got
birth control covered I believe that
today we have another landmark
opportunity
the viagra patent is expiring next year
we have more licensing agreements which
is why we're seeing tremendous IDI
advertisements I think this is an
opportunity to once again point to the
double standards and make sure we bring
women's health along and what I ask is
will we use this opportunity to make
sure that women's sexual wellness is
included or will we stick with the
status quo at Stanford GSB at our
Graduate School of Business we talk
about changing lives changing
organizations and changing the world you
may not think that your job or your job
after business school has the potential
to change sex lives change organizations
and change the world but if your job
touches on advertising payments banking
investing finance packaging
manufacturing insurance or determining
who has a voice at accelerators or at
trade shows let alone if you work in law
the social sector education or the
public sector you will actually be in a
position to make decisions that impact
people including in the intimate aspects
of our lives when I think about well I
want to show you a picture of this is my
dad my sister and I the day that we
moved my younger sister into college
when she was around the age I got the
talk I told you about and when I think
about 19 year olds me and the messages I
heard from my dad they are so different
than the inequities that I've
experienced and from the realities I
talked about today 19 year old me heard
that my pleasure mattered just as much
as any other man's if not more
nineteen-year-old me heard that I had
agency over my body and that my
sexuality was mine nineteen year old me
heard that intimacy could be a rich
source of positivity in my life and a
source of deep connection with other
people these are the realities I want
for all women and for people of all
genders all sexual orientations and all
sexual identities it is time that
women's sexual well-being is valued as
much as men's in business and in our
culture
[Applause]
[Music]